DC like I said they control these
characters and we went through a period
where DC was like we've got plans for
Deathstroke that don't involve our yeah
I know I got it yeah that changed the
end of this year busily I basically you
know we knew we were going to Leon you
and we had see Slade Wilson so I went to
DC and I said listen I know you guys
have plans for him and you know that's
all cool but you got to give us this one
because we can't go to Leon you and
that's he Slade Wilson and as part of
those conversations we also were like
and he'll need to be in the season
premiere of season six because that fit
ties into you know our plans and it
would be really great if we could you
know tell really a Slade Wilson centric
story we've never really truly done that
so we're doing a cool two-parter
episodes five and six this year where
the the flashbacks will be from slaves
perspective and it's very much a Slade
Oliver two-hander it's it's always great
having mono on the show and again it's
like we just have to operate you know
within you know the no I governments of
of DC hey everybody so there's all kinds
of Deathstroke bombs dropping all over
the DC Universe so there's Justice
League Deathstroke I'll explain what's
going on with him Joe Manganiello is a
badass even though there's been a bunch
of changes going on behind the scenes
with the Batman franchise there's still
gonna be Deathstroke stuff happening in
the DC EU and then obviously you've
probably heard about the Deathstroke
origin story that they're doing on TV so
that's going to be a two-part episode
and they've already revealed a whole
bunch of information they've cast Joseph
Wilson who's gonna be Jericho from the
comics and we're in the middle of a
couple new giveaways so I wanted to
explain what's going on with giveaways
this season for like all the DC stuff so
I'll explain that at the end of the
video we'll do the Deathstroke stuff
first but make sure you subscribe to get
everything because we are getting ready
to roll into all this stuff coming back
so let's start with DC EU stuff first
because I know people have been asking
me to do a Batman video because of all
the stuff that's been flying around even
Geoff Johns has been making fun of
people for spreading rumors that aren't
true about what's going on with the ben
affleck batman franchise so there's a
solo Batman movie that's happening
people thought that it wasn't going to
be connected to the DC EU but it turns
out the reason why people thought that
was wrong the director came out
clarified statements that he made and
just explained that his Batman movie was
going to be relatively self-contained
what he's saying makes it sound more
like it's going to be like the guardians
of the galaxy to thing where yes it's
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
yes there's small points of crossover
but like how many times do the guardians
talk about what happened during Avengers
they don't talk about it at all so just
assume that that's what's going on but
what happened is is that the Deathstroke
of the DC EU Joe Manganiello they did
all these screen tests you probably saw
the teaser videos that I did for it
earlier this year they had originally
intended him to be a part of the Geoff
Johns written Batman movie Ben Affleck
and Geoff Johns wrote a treatment for
that solo movie but then when the new
director came in he said that he wanted
to find the character himself just
because he hadn't been a part of the DC
EU and then of course people were asking
Joe Manganiello are you still gonna be
in this new Batman movie if they're
changing the story and his basic
response is is that yes he knows but he
can't say like you know kind of gives
the shrug answer which is typical
default answer for most of the big comic
book movie actors they can't say
anything they have snipers trained on
them ready to take them out if they
spoil stuff so you probably heard about
the crazy number of DC films they just
announced we're in development there's
like three different Joker movies all by
themselves
there's even Suicide Squad - that just
got a new director so there's so much
stuff happening of course Deathstroke is
still gonna be a part of the DC EU even
if he does get taken out of the Batman
movie so sort of segwaying into TV
Deathstroke as that clip from Marc
Guggenheim implied there's been a lot of
issues with them using the character on
arrow because of the plans that DC has
for him in other places that just means
that because he's gonna be in the movies
they don't want him to be on TV all the
time
it's interesting cuz cuz you know like
there's a whole bunch of new characters
on that show to be honest in the in the
first episode which I can't really talk
about can I
but there was this moment where I'm
meant to be with the rest of them mm-hmm
you know and this scene was written that
you know the group and Slade Deathstroke
run off together and I said that I said
that Marc Guggenheim I said is this
gonna be a musical like no no but III
asked him I said I it sort of doesn't
feel right does it might be great with
me and so said there's a very specific
scene where I say it's in the trailer
this is trailer that's out now for
season six hey Oliver says there's a
boat on the Eastern Shore you luck won't
make it in time
I'll take my own chances and I say I'll
take my own chances yeah and I walk off
and I'm kind of just wanting to preserve
the the strength of the relationship
between Slade and Oliver just on that
level because it's it's such a sort of
stand-alone little relationship but I
just don't want to get caught up in the
group and be like a high five but like
he says come to this season they were
going back to the island so he went to
DC and was like look we can't go back to
the island and blow everything up and
not explain what happened - Deathstroke
so you have to let us use the character
so they're like okay fine you can use
destro we'll do a self contain two parts
story arc it'll sort of sync up with the
theme of family it Oliver will help
destro find his son Joseph in
present-day because he's still alive we
know that Grant Wilson exists on an
alternate earth in there's been no
mention of rose Wilson yet so they've
cast their Jericho but the character
description actually reads a little bit
like he might become the new version of
ravager on the TV show because Jericho
and grant are like two completely
different types of characters in the
comics so the TV description reads Joe
Wilson is followed in his father's
footsteps by joining the secret
Australian military agency ASIS after
years of brutal combat Joe now finds
himself in a remote kaznian prison under
the alias Cain Wolfman fighting for his
life so during the two-part episode
they're going to tell the Deathstroke
origin story so there'll be flashbacks
for Deathstroke and there'll be stuff
happening in present-day where he and
Oliver go to kaznia
to break his son out of that prison so
here's the description for how Joe
Wilson is now working for this special
agency he just sounds like he's turning
into Grant Wilson Grant Wilson went to
hive they gave him the serum that turned
him into crazy Ravager and then that
sort of threw him into the path of the
Teen Titans he tried to take them down
and ended up dying in the process so it
was a very tragic end for that character
but because they've already done hive on
arrow
and because Titans the TV show will
probably want to use that organization
they're probably being a couple minor
changes to arrow so I'll try to explain
that when the episodes air you may have
also spotted the easter egg in there
Joseph's codename
kein Wolfman so that's an amalgam of
Adeline Kane who's his mother
Deathstroke's wife and Marv Wolfman the
creator of the character from the comics
so I think the big question here is is
what are they gonna do with the
Deathstroke character after this
two-part episode will he pop back up
during the back half of the season it's
a bit of a Superman situation where it's
like the TV shows get to use the really
big characters but only a couple times
so because we already have vigilante
Michael Emerson and Richard Dragan
coming on to arrow it sounds like if
Deathstroke does come back in the back
half of the season it'll be very limited
or not at all and he'll just pop up on
Titans from now on so I can't say a
whole lot about Deathstroke on Titans
they've just cast all the characters
I've already done a big video for that
so I'll add a link to that video at the
end of this I'm really excited about it
but it won't premiere till next year but
the other really important thing people
were asking a lot of questions about the
giveaways there's been so many new
subscribers that have come to the
channel if you found me for the first
time this year then welcome to the
channel you guys are totally awesome I
try to do weekly giveaways just as a way
to say thank you to everybody the rules
are really simple they're only open to
subscribers so if you're not all you
have to do is be a subscriber and then
just leave a comment is a sort of way to
make yourself known I picked the winners
from the comments usually what I do is
when you win a giveaway I'll put your
channel icon in the video and say your
name like hey you won please private
message me so I can get your contact
details when I say that if you're
relatively new to YouTube or you're not
watching on desktop there's an about
page for my youtube channel with a
little button that says message you
click that you send me a private message
just let me know hey you know I want to
giveaway and then once I see that I'll
reply to you and arrange for you to get
the giveaway so in the spirit of that I
will say congratulations to the latest
flash ring giveaway winner generic
pop-tart please private message me so I
can get your contact details right now
it's for the flash ring it'll be for
Justice League imax tickets when those
go on sale in another week or two
so hopefully that explains everything
I'll just remind everybody about
giveaway stuff every once in a while
because there's always a bunch of new
people that come in every season for all
the shows so while you wait for
everything you can click
here for a brand new thor footage and
you can click here to learn about all
those new Titans characters thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight